بل عادي والطبيعي انه يوم الزفاف من اسعد
ايام العريس والعروسه بس هذه القاعده يبدو
مو عند الكل بتزبط خصوصا في عريس صيني
تحول فرحه لكابوس فخلال الزفه هو وعروسته
ظهر فجاه 12 فزاره رفعين لافته بالاحمر
وساكتين ما بيتكلموا حرف لكن رغم كل هذا
الشيء قلبوا الفرح فوق تحت الفتيات هدول
اتضح انهم حبيبات العريس السابقات
واللافته كان مكتوب عليها نحن عاشقات
شنسون السابقات واليوم سوف ندمرك
تكه حاملين فيصل
[موسيقى]
بعد المشهد الرهيب هذا اعترف العريس بانه
تصرف بشكل سيء مع بعض صديقاته السابقات في
الماضي وجرح كثير بنات بس قال انه الان
نضج وتغير واعتذر عن تصرفاته السابقه وقال
انه عروسته وعائلته رافضين يتكلموا معاه
قبل ما يعطيهم تفسير لمشهد الزفاف الغريب
يعني فوق الفضيحه كمان يعني المهم صار في
ورطه كمان رغم البهدله العلنيه هذه لكن
منصات التواصل الصينيه صراحه ما تعاطفوا
ابدا مع العريس ولا حتى شويه يعني
[موسيقى]